Russia marked Orthodox Easter in Ukraine
with a barrage of missiles
with a church
among the targets on Easter Sunday.
Villagers search the rubble
near the city of
Aparicio, where
their church suffered massive damage
No services were underway
when the missile hit and no one was hurt.
But the head of the local military
was incensed, saying nothing is sacred.
And there was no lull in the ferocious
fighting in and around back Mort.
Ukraine says almost 100 Russian shellings
were recorded around the city
in just 24 hours,
and about 30 firefights
raged between Ukrainian
and Russian forces
for control of the devastated city.
But there was also
a little joy on this holiday.
130 Ukrainians are now free
after a prisoner exchange with Russia
Russian President Vladimir Putin met
with Chinese
Defense Minister
Li Sheng Fu in Moscow on Sunday,
just weeks
after Chinese leader
Xi Jinping also visited the country.
Mr.
Putin told Li that President
Xi's visit
was, quote, very productive
and he praised their countries
bilateral cooperation in multiple areas,
including the military
and we hear them.
There is
a very good development of relations
between our countries in all areas
in the economic,
social, cultural and educational sectors.
But we are also working actively
through the military departments
And this was Lee's
first foreign trip
since becoming defense minister.
He emphasized the,
quote, special character
and strategic importance of the Moscow
Beijing relationship.
CNN's Clare Sebastian
is following
all these developments for us.
She joins us live from London.
Good morning to Claire.
So President Putin met
with China's defense minister.
What came out of that meeting?
Yeah, Rosemary.
Nothing concrete,
although obviously that was a meeting
that was going to be
very closely watched.
Given what we know, about the U.S.
concerns that China may be considering
supplying military aid
for Russia's war in Ukraine.
Nothing obvious came out.
But these optics matter
this is the third high level
Chinese visit to Moscow
in as many months.
We first had the top
diplomat, then, as you
mentioned, the president
himself, Xi Jinping.
And now the new defense minister
in his first overseas trip in that role.
Very significant
to see the commitment,
the level of engagement on both sides.
And I think to some degree,
the target
audience of those optics
was the United States,
the Chinese defense minister
not missing an opportunity
to mention the Cold War,
saying that Moscow and Beijing
have very strong relations
that far surpassed
the military political alliances
of the Cold War.
I think a pretty clear statement
on the fact that both sides are hoping
this relationship will serve
as a counterpoint
to the US led alliance and its support
for Ukraine, even though,
of course, publicly, Beijing
has not officially expressed support
for Russia's war, it continues to foster
that relationship.
So, as I say, no concrete
steps emerging from this meeting,
but very significant updates
as we watch
how this relationship unfolds. Unclear.
What is the latest on
fighting around Vamos?
So an
exceptionally violent, bloody weekend
for as many,
according to the Ukrainian side,
the spokesperson for the eastern
grouping of the Ukrainian armed forces
said that there was an unprecedented
in recent decades level
of fighting over the weekend,
and that has continued
into Monday morning.
The Ukrainian general staff
saying that Russia is attacking
its suburbs,
including locations
on the supply routes
that Ukraine uses
to get food and medicine ammunition in
and of course, wounded soldiers out.
They have said in recent days
that their supply routes
remain open,
but clearly
they are coming under attack now.
Also over the weekend,
the Russian Ministry of Defense
reported that Wagner
had captured two districts to the north
and south of Buchman.
We have not been able
to independently verify that,
but I think that shows,
you know,
eight and a half months into this battle
just how incremental it still
is to districts in a town
that had a pre-war population
of only 70,000 Rosemary.
All right.
Our thanks to Clare Sebastian
joining us live from London.